supongamos que puedo hoy entrevistarme
con cada una de las personas de una
población lo cual generalmente no es
algo práctico y generalmente no lo
podemos hacer pero supongamos que puedo
hacerlo entonces llegó y les pregunto
qué opinan del presidente y tienen dos
opciones pueden tener una opinión
desfavorable del presidente o pueden
tener una opinión favorable del
presidente
digamos que después de que le pregunté a
cada una de las personas de la población
40 por ciento tienen una opinión
desfavorable y 60% tiene una opinión
favorable entonces a ver déjame de
verdad aquí dibujo la función de
distribución de esta variable tiene
únicamente dos posibles valores puede
tener un valor desfavorable o un valor
favorable
y 40 por ciento tiene una opinión
desfavorable aquí vamos a ponerle
colores aquí hay 40% con opinión
desfavorable bajada 40%
60% tiene una opinión favorable
vamos a ponerle el color azul 60 por
ciento tiene una opinión favorable del
presidente nota que estos dos números
suman 100% porque todos los individuos
tienen que tener opinión desfavorable o
favorable ahora si yo te pidiera que
escogiera un individuo de la población
al azar y te preguntará qué tipo de
opinión deberíamos esperar de esta
persona que obtendríamos bueno otra
forma de pensar en eso es cuál es la
esperanza de esta distribución de esta
variable aleatoria
ahora para una variable como esta una
variable discreta la esperanza es la
suma de los valores que pueden tomar por
la probabilidad de que tome cada uno de
esos valores ahora no podemos tomar uu
por la probabilidad de que tome
efe por la probabilidad que toma el
valor f porque no nos va a dar ningún
tipo de número entonces pues tenemos que
asignarle algún número alguna efe no
digamos que aún le asignamos el número
cero y a efe le asignamos el número uno
ahora entonces si ya podemos sacar la
esperanza y nos la dan un número
concreto no
bueno a ver la esperanza de esta
distribución va a ser igual punto 4 que
es la probabilidad que la variable toma
el valor 0 por el valor 0
punto 6 que es la probabilidad de que la
variable tome el valor 1 por el valor un
nuevo
lo cual va a ser igual a esto nada más
va a ser 0.6 por 1 que es punto 6
entonces a ver la variable no puede
tomar el valor punto 0.6 ningún
individuo te puede decir 'estoy punto 6
a favor del presidente presidente y
tampoco estoy punto 4 en contra cada uno
tiene que escoger ya sea favorable o
desfavorable nunca vas a encontrar a
alguien que te conteste punto 6 siempre
vas a obtener o 0 o 1 este es un ejemplo
donde la variable aleatoria nunca puede
tomar el valor de su esperanza su valor
esperado está más o menos por aquí pero
obviamente no puede pasar pero sigue
siendo la esperanza ahora la razón por
la cual esto tiene sentido es que si le
preguntas a 100 personas esperas más o
menos que 60 personas te digan tengan
una opinión favorable
40 por ciento que tenga una opinión
desfavorable 40 personas
cuál es la varianza de esta variable
dilatoria
la varianza vamos a escribirla por acá
con otro color la varianza es
simplemente la podemos ver como la suma
de las probabilidades de que la variable
tome un valor por la distancia al
cuadrado que hay entre ese valor y la
esperanza ahora hay únicamente dos
valores que puede tomar la variable 0 o
1 entonces la probabilidad de que
obtengas 0.4 entonces aquí ponemos punto
4 y luego lo tenemos que multiplicar por
la distancia del 0 ahora la esperanza y
luego elevarlo al cuadrado
entonces 0 - punto 6
0 - puntos después podemos haber puesto
puntos 6 0 y después elevarlo al
cuadrado pero como estamos elevando al
cuadrado da lo mismo
ok entonces esta es la diferencia entre
el 0 y la esperanza al cuadrado más
baja la probabilidad que obtengamos un
13.6 por la distancia de 1 a la media a
la esperanza que es punto 6 y después la
vamos a elevar al cuadrado también aquí
la elevamos al cuadrado entonces saber
cuál es este valor esto va a ser punto 4
por punto 6 al cuadrado
pero este valor que es negativo que es
punto 6 a la hora de llevarlo al
cuadrado nos queda lo mismo que punto 6
al cuadrado no que es punto 36 entonces
ese valor es punto 36 y después este
valor de acá vamos a subrayarlo con otro
color entonces aquí nos quedan más
puntos 6 por un 9 menos puntos 6 al
cuadrado
ahora 1 menos puntos 6 es punto 4 que al
elevarlo al cuadrado nos queda punto 16
entonces ese valor de aquí es punto 16
no dejen mi calculadora miren qué padre
calculadora tengo aquí
ponemos la por acá esto va a ser punto 4
por punto 36
más puntos 6 x
por punto 16
lo cual es igual a punto 24 bien
entonces nuestra desviación estándar es
punto 24 0.24
o si quieren pensar en la varianza no
esperen se esperen a ver esta esta es la
varianza que hay la varianza de 0.24 y
la desviación estándar es nada más la
raíz de esto que la desviación estándar
es la raíz de 0.24 regresemos a la
calculadora para ver que sacar la raíz
es la raíz de punto 24 es igual a punto
48 9 y un montón de cosas pero bueno
mejor redondeamos lo no esto es más o
menos no se ha redondeado igual a 0.49
ahora nuestra media nuestra esperanza es
3.6 y está por acá
y nuestra desviación estándar es se
acerca muchísimo al 5 entonces está más
o menos por acá acercándose muchísimo al
1.1 por abajo entonces esta es una
desviación estándar hacia arriba y una
desviación estándar hacia abajo está
como por acá lo cual tiene sentido no es
un poco difícil tener una buena
intuición con variables aleatorias
discretas porque no pueden tomar ninguno
de esos valores pero tiene sentido que
la distribución esté más cargada hacia
la derecha hice este ejemplo con estos
números en particular porque quería
enseñarles porque es útil esta
distribución en el siguiente vídeo haré
esto con números generales 60 va a ser p
la probabilidad de éxito 40 va a ser un
números p la probabilidad de fracaso y
obtendremos fórmulas para la esperanza
varianza y desviación estándar de esta
variable aleatoria que se llama
distribución bernouilli que es un caso
particular de la distribución binomial